(mid-tempo music)
- Well, welcome back to another
episode of The Addy Hour."
It's always my honor and privilege
to host these conversations.
And today, I'm grateful to be able to host
Jeremy Lin and Esther Choo
for conversation about
mental health, race,
wellness, and culture
in a AAPI communities.
So these are two individuals
that likely need no introduction
to you all as listeners,
but I'm gonna go ahead
and give them a brief
introduction, anyway.
Starting out with Esther Choo.
Dr. Choo is a physician
and popular health science communicator.
She's known as bold and innovative voice
on gender and racial equity in healthcare.
And she's also advocate for new frameworks
for birthing positive and
productive workplaces.
She graduated from Yale
University as undergrad,
also went to the Yale School
of Medicine for med school,
and currently has an NIH
funded research program
where she's looking at health
services and health policy
as a researcher.
She's also the founding
member of Times Up Healthcare.
She has also been very active
in the pandemic, as well,
where she's helped raise awareness
about the critical shortage
of personal protective
equipment or PPE in hospitals.
She also is a Chief
Medical Officer of Duke,
which builds mobile healthcare units.
As someone who's been very active
in a lot of different roles.
She also has numerous commentaries,
which regularly appear
in different places,
including the New England
Journal of Medicine.
The Harvard Business Review,
NBC Thinks, (indistinct)
and the Washington Post.
She's also a regular
columnist for the Lancet
and she regularly
appears on CNN and MSNBC.
So someone who is deeply invested
in a lot of different spheres of influence
and who continues to make an
impact within her profession
and in the general community, as well.
So I'm honored to welcome Dr. Esther too,
to The Addy Hour podcast.
Thanks for being here.
- Thanks for having me on.
- Of course.
The second guest I'd like to introduce
is none other than Jeremy Lin.
Jeremy is a Paulo Alto native,
and of course is one of
the few Asian-Americans
to ever play in the NBA.
Prior to his NBA career,
he actually played four seasons at Harvard
where he was an All Ivy first
team selection, two times,
both in 2009 and 2010.
As a Yale professor.
I'm giving him a little bit of grace
for playing for the other team
partially because he
played for Coach Amaker
who was also a Duke
graduate, as I am myself.
So I couldn't help myself, I
had to throw that in there,
but Jeremy, as many of you all know
is someone who after being undrafted
and playing the NBA for a couple years,
rose to a level of stardom
as Linsanity took off as
an overnight sensation.
I actually remember the game
that he played against
the New Jersey Nets.
I remember seeing that in real time
and just having known
who he was over the years
was really excited to see what
was happening in that moment.
He, of course, has played for
lots of different NBA teams,
including the Warriors,
the Knicks and the Rockets.
He's currently playing
for the Beijing Ducks
in the 2021 to 2022 season
and I believe you all
are in the play offs,
so wanna wish him the best
of luck in that, as well.
Also wanted to highlight
some of the different community things
that he's been involved in.
In 2020, his Be The Light
campaign donated $1.4 million
to COVID relief efforts
and helped raise greater awareness
of increasing anti-Asian
racism during the pandemic.
He's also been appointed
as UNICEF USA's ambassador
and in that role he uses his platform
to champion children's rights
and to also help create more
equitable world for every child
His Jeremy Lin Foundation
also serves over 22,000 youth
and they've done this through
grants, narrative change,
community empowerment
and racial solidarity.
So again, someone who
has used his platform
and continued to be really
invested in the community
and I'm honored to welcome Jeremy Lin
to The Addy Hour podcast,
thanks for being here.
- Thanks for having me. I'm excited.
- Of course, and I'm glad to
have this come to fruition.
This is something we've
actually been talking about
for quite a while
and took some time to get
everything coordinated.
So again, grateful to both of you
for being able to be here today.
But as my listeners know, I
always like to just check in
and see how people are doing overall.
So want to just get a sense
of how you're both doing,
at this point in time
and also what your day to day looks like
if as much as you'd be willing to share.
So Jeremy why don't we go in reverse order
and start with you.
- Yeah, I currently, last night,
well, it's morning right now in China.
And so last night,
we got to the playoff
bubble in Ankang in China.
And so the whole season has
been played in different bubbles
and these bubbles are in different cities.
So we can only be in the
hotel and go to the gym
and the arena to compete
and then come back.
And so we just got here,
our first playoff game is in three days.
and from there it's gonna be,
just we'll see how far we go,
but it's gonna be four round playoffs
and that's basically it.
Other than that, I've been over here
for the last about nine,
10 months for this season
and so it's about to wind down.
We're about to see how
the season finishes,
but everything else is great, I'm excited.
And I'm excited to talk with Dr. Choo
and didn't realize we had a
lot of Yale background here.
I wasn't warned of this when
I came into this podcast
but I think I'll do my best.
No, we'll be okay.
- You're gonna hold your own.
- Let's just keep it civil
while we're recording,
and then it can all break down after that.
- Well, definitely appreciate it.
Maybe it's the reason we
didn't warn you ahead of time,
but like I said, I'm sure
you're gonna hold your own
and congrats on making the playoffs too.
One quick follow up question.
just as you were describing
the bubbles and all that,
what was it like coming
from here in the US?
Not that you haven't been in China before,
but especially during this time
in transitioning into a different place
where there are different
protocols in place,
how has that process been for you?
- It's been the most
eye opening experience
just to get to China,
the amount of work, the amount of tests,
things that you have to do,
and I'll touch on this probably later in.
Before I took off, I was negative.
I landed, I was negative,
but on my third day of my
21 day hotel quarantine,
I tested positive for COVID.
I still don't know how
and no one else on the
flight was positive.
And I ended up spending 11
weeks in isolated quarantine
in a very small room in
the hospital, in the hotel,
and so when I say like
the amount of, I mean,
we'll get into this later,
but it was almost three months
where I did not see the outside
or breathe any air from the outside
and you couldn't do laundry,
you couldn't do anything.
It was quite an experience.
And that definitely, we'll
talk about mental health
and all that later, but it is different.
But then now here it's
a zero tolerance policy.
And so when you're in a
country of 1.5 billion,
they basically have hardly
any cases, very, very few.
and they're typically all
from people who are flying in.
And so it's also very different
because when you're
walking around day to day,
there's essentially no threat.
I mean, you are basically
living in a bubble already,
but we're in a bubble
inside of a bubble, yeah.
- Wow, that's a totally different setup
in a lot of ways.
So, I mean, I appreciate you sharing that
and giving people some insight
into what that experience
has been like too.
'Cause I think it's important for us
to realize how different things are moving
in different parts of the world.
And then also, like you mentioned
some of the outcomes of that too,
but I'm sure we'll loop back to that
just in terms of the mental
health component of that too,
as you mentioned, so.
- Yeah.
- Esther what about you?
How's life been for you these days
especially as an ER doctor
with everything that we're
continuing to navigate?
- Yeah, it's so interesting
to hear your story Jeremy,
because I mean, there's
that element of my life.
that's about the ER,
and it's kind of not what you think.
I mean, we definitely have these surges
and in Oregon, the most recent surges,
the delta and omicron, were
really the most significant.
We dodged a lot of the
caseload from the early waves.
It just didn't really hit Oregon hard
and then we were hit a harder later.
But during the surges you
have a lot of empathy.
Everyone's like, how are
you doing? Is the ER, okay?
But when you kind of mobilize
your energy and your spirit
for those surges
and what I think, what
people don't realize
is that between the surges
is actually really hard too,
because that's when everything
comes crashing down on you.
I mean, all of that care that was delayed,
people held off going to the hospital,
the surgeries were put off.
We use a ton of people resources,
and then the surge is over
and all of that kind of
comes crashing down on you.
And so, I mean, there's a piece
that just was published
by a friend of mine
in the Washington Post
that was enumerating all the shortages
that we have in the emergency department.
I mean, supply chains are
still affected globally,
so we don't have things
like saline bags, IV tubing,
the ability to measure kidney function,
a host of medications that
you use every single day.
Every other day is a
medication shortage notice.
Like this drug that you need,
that you just think will always be there
is in short supply.
Periodically, different types of PPE,
the protective gear still in short supply.
And then the biggest one of course
is the human supply that
we're running out of
because we've lost a fifth
or more of our workforce,
many, many nurses
we're always scrambling
just to fill shifts.
And so I don't really remember
what normal was in the hospital before,
but we don't have it during surges,
we don't have it after surges.
We're always diverting patients away
as a specialty hospital.
And so there is that whole element
and then I think just like what's striking
as I listen to Jeremy,
tell a story about these like
incredibly rigorous processes
to keep people safe.
And then I know you're
in a special NBA bubble
within that bubble,
but I would say we are now in the US,
in this really surreal environment
where people are completely
not taking any precautions.
There's still not adequate testing.
We don't have surveillance
programs in most settings.
I went to church the other day
and my family was the only one in masks,
with a third of the congregation elderly
and people coughing and
sneezing in a closed space.
And it's not even suggested to be careful
and just in a lot of places
in the United States,
there's no concept of the fact
that there is a global pandemic happening
and we contribute to that
with our individual decision making.
So that has been really
demoralizing to see for people
who are spending so much
time in the hospital
and sealing the tail end of that.
Because of course there's a lot of people
who because of misinformation
or because of their medical conditions
are not able to be vaccinated
to have good protections from coronavirus
when they're exposed.
But that being said,
I mean, I've been in
the ER this entire time.
I sometimes am not perfect about my PPE.
Somehow I feel like I should knock on wood
and I'm cursing myself,
but somehow I have not gotten COVID yet.
And so, you never take that for granted,
but we've been really blessed.
My husband is a physician also.
We've both been exposed many times
in our community and at work
and so far our whole family
has stayed pretty healthy.
So just feeling very
lucky too, to this point
to have had that gift in our lives.
- Yeah, definitely a
blessing in a lot of ways.
I appreciate you just even
peeling back the layers
to just give all the perspectives.
I think so much of the
time, it's easy for people
who aren't in the medical
setting day to day
to realize what's happening in between
and all the challenges
that are still there.
So I appreciate that level of honesty
and just the realness of it too.
But like you said also,
the blessing of not
having contracted COVID
and just being able to
continue to walk through
in a lot of ways, so thanks for that.
That perspective in a lot of ways,
to both of you, just for the PPCRA
it's starting to bring out,
I know it's a lot we could unpack
from just those two
comments that you both made,
but one thing that we'll
do in the conversation too,
is also kind of lean
into AAPI space of things
to the Asian American
Pacific Islander component.
And I did just wanna lead
off just acknowledging
that that's a very imperfect
term in a lot of ways,
even though that's what we often
use in these conversations.
So I wanted to make sure
that that was also a point of emphasis
and also just with the
expectation that I would imagine
our listeners are not going
to be expecting the two of you
to speak on behalf of
the entire, racially
diverse AAPI communities
in that sense, as well,
but then also just having some insights
from your experiences too,
just based on the experiences
you've had in your own lives
and the interactions
with family and friends
and things like that.
So not that those were disclaimers,
but I also just wanted to make sure
that we really, keep things in context
'cause it's so easy
sometimes to over generalize,
but then it's also easy
to miss the important
components that are there.
So as much as we can kind of
hold both of those together,
I think is important.
But just to start out,
I know we'll get into the
mental health component
a little bit too,
but just wanted to hear a little bit
about both of your experiences
in terms of growing up,
just in your communities en large
and how this aspect of being
a member of the AAPI community
has also factored into that.
So Esther asked you if
we could start with you,
that'd be great.
- Yeah, sure. I am the child of immigrants
and my parents moved here for grad school
from South Korea, what is now South Korea
and then never left.
They kind of thought they were coming
just for my father's education.
This is in the 1960s,
so this is a very common story for Koreans
who had a similar background,
and ended up having their
kids here and then never left.
So I was born here in the United States
and we lived in a pretty, not
ethically diverse community
on the west side of Cleveland.
And so I didn't grow up
around a lot of other Koreans,
but we did go to Korean
church for a while.
And so that was kind of my exposure.
So really almost the
entirety of my experience
with other Asians was my
family, my immediate family
and my extended family.
But I think some of those things
really carried over nicely
to what I experienced
when I was part of a
larger Asian community
from college onwards.
I think in terms of some of the topics
we're gonna talk about later on in this
or throughout this podcast,
I think, just, I don't
ever remember mental health
being part of the conversation.
I do think kind of being
stoic and strong and resilient
and not sharing your feelings too much
was kind of the ethos in my family.
We just weren't a warm,
it was very loving,
but there was not a
lot of warm, fuzzy talk
and certainly we never spoke
about what I now understand
were a lot of mental health problems
across our extended family.
You kind of understood
that somebody was ill
and had to go away for a while,
or there was just that
cousin who was very shy
and so never came out where
the rest of us were gathering.
And only much later
when we started talking
about these things,
did we realize that we weren't perfect.
What was happening is we just didn't talk
about things like
substance use, addiction,
mental health, suicide, those things
and we're all given kinda euphemisms
or completely not addressed
at all and not talked about.
So I think even mentioning
things like being depressed,
or needing therapy or
needing to be on medications,
those are things I all
learned on my own as an adult
and really had to reconcile them
against kind of the implicit
values and practices
that I learned growing up.
- I appreciate you sharing that
and giving that perspective and
that honesty again, as well.
Jeremy, what about for you?
- Yeah, my background
is pretty interesting.
My grandparents born
and raised in Zhejiang,
which is a province
and they grew up in a city,
like driving distance from Shanghai.
Actually it was like 10 minutes
away from the COVID hospital
that I spent all that time at.
And then my parents were
born and raised in Taipei
and then I was born and
raised in California.
And so growing up was really interesting
because similar to Dr. Choo,
my main exposure to other Asians
was basically just at home
or when I would go to church.
And I went to a Chinese church
and so there, it was like my Asian circle.
And I was also very fit
in with how I was raised
and the culture that I was raised in.
But then I grew up in Paulo Alto,
which is primarily white community,
going to school, primarily white,
and Harvard, as well,
just having that kind
of school background.
But then I would play basketball
I'd play competitive basketball
I'm playing in the AU circuit.
And so it felt like that was
primarily African American.
And so it felt like I had
these three different worlds
that I lived in.
And there was nobody that
could really understand,
if I had someone in one circle,
they might not understand what it was like
in one of the other circles.
And there wasn't that much carryover
and so aside from being
at home and at church,
I was always kind of
like labeled a little bit
as like, because people
knew I played basketball,
but then, it was always
like, yo, he's the Asian,
he's Asian basketball player.
That's the Asian basketball player.
And so it never really felt like I could,
it always felt like I was like
for, I guess, a good reason
they respected that I
could play basketball,
but it was always kind of
like, "Oh, he's the Asian."
And so that was just something
that I kind of got used to,
but that was my experience.
And very similar to Dr. Choo,
just a lot of things
weren't really talked about
when it came to mental health,
even things I had to learn about,
many things I learned about
once I became a professional
basketball player,
and start just have to tap
into the mind and sports
psychology a little bit more,
but it was something
where even as of late,
when I started to go to therapy
one of the initial
questions that was asked me
by one of my parents
like, "Oh, what's wrong?
Like, "Are you sure? You
might not need that."
And it was not ill intentioned at all.
It was just, it's like,
"Oh no, you don't need it,"
or "You need medication?" or "No, no, no."
Like immediately it's
like, 'Oh, what's wrong."
Instead of it kind of being seen as,
this is just a very helpful life tool
that can be used to process emotions,
to get through certain things,
to be able to just be a better person,
like you would want to eat
healthy, you wanna work out,
you wanna sleep well,
and you wanna do things for
your holistic wellbeing.
This is definitely, very important part,
that plays into that.
- Yeah. Appreciate you sharing that.
And again, I mean, there's
so many overlapping themes
as you were talking between, both of you
just in terms of navigating
different spaces,
being here in the States,
having those family connections
and sometimes other connections,
but then also kind of trying to navigate
between different
cultural groups, as well.
But I mean, it also seems
like the theme of that
was just the mental health component
wasn't really talked about all that much.
Now I'd say, maybe as an outsider,
that's kind of been similar
to some of my perceptions, as well.
So in college,
I did have a couple of Korean
American roommates, as well.
I did join them at their
Korean churches at times.
So I got to dabble here and there
and experience some of the culture.
It's funny, I remember
at one point also playing
and I can't remember
the name of the league,
but there was like a basketball tournament
at the University of
North Carolina Chapel Hill
for one of the Asian Student Associations.
Every team was allowed one
non-Asian basketball player.
Of course, every non-Asian
basketball player was black,
so ended up being those two groups.
I don't know why I went there,
but so maybe Jeremy
talking about basketball
just reminded me of that,
that's its own interesting phenomenon,
but just kind of some
of those cultural pieces
that I've just seen them navigate
and have been able to
navigate with them, as well.
But again, just that mental health piece,
I don't ever remember
that being talked about
and this is late '90s, early 2000s.
And then even the 2010s,
there were lots of different articles
from different colleges
where people would talk about,
the silent struggles that
students were having.
Often they were talking about
Asian-American communities,
black and brown communities,
just that people were kind of navigating
and struggling and walking
through in silence,
not feeling like they had
any space to talk about it,
or they would get some help on campus,
but then go home and feel like
they couldn't bring that
same conversation up
because of all the different ways
that things were looked at.
So, I mean, I think I'm mirroring a lot
of what you all have said,
and I'm just curious if you've
seen things shift in a sense.
I mean, Jeremy talked
about going to therapy
after you talked about knowing
what some of those things are now.
Have you seen things shift
in terms of acknowledgement
in different AAPI communities?
Or do you think it's more
at the individual level
at this point or a mixture of both?
- In my personal experience,
I've definitely seen at
least some level of shift
because there's just a lot
more people talking about it,
but maybe it's in certain
circles, or whatever,
but even within my own family,
as well as a lot of my friends
as they start to talk about it,
because mental health has
become one of the biggest things
since the pandemic
that at least, certain areas,
are starting to make pushes for
in terms of explosion awareness.
And so even, in my foundation,
just we talked to some kids,
from some of the grantees
and they're talking about,
and they're going home and
talking to their parents
and they're talking about
how they need more mental health
resources in their schools.
And it's definitely a different vibe
than when I was growing up
and I think even after,
between me and some of my friends
and us talking about our
mental health with our parents,
I started to see some
different shifts happening.
I mean, a great example that
I had, was this past year
I went to eat with like
six or seven people,
And they're primarily my agents in China
and as well as another athlete in the CBA,
another basketball player
in the CBA and some friends,
and as we were all eating,
we started to kind of
talk about panic attacks.
And so we had mentioned this
concept of panic attacks
and immediately one person was like,
"Oh is it, really, that happens?.
Like, I didn't realize
that like, wait so,"
and he started asking these questions
and he was like, "Man,
they can't be that common."
What ended up happening by
the end of the conversation,
everybody went around
and said that they have had panic attacks,
multiple panic attacks.
And this group of friends,
has been friends for over a decade
and they'd never talked about
it and never knew about it
and never heard of it.
And every single person
went around talking
about how they had a panic attack here,
or this person struggled
panic attacks occasionally,
or this person had one here.
And all of a sudden it was like,
at the end of the conversation,
the guy was like, my agent was like,
"Wow, so it looks like I might
be the only one at this table
who has no idea what this feels like.
And so it was just
really eye opening to me
to realize, like, because when
you go through these things,
you feel alone
and you feel like you
don't know who to talk to.
There's no one else that
you can talk to about
and so that kind of
really challenged me too,
to like to continue to
try to use my voice,
my platform more and to kind
of fight more for mental health
and breaking that stigma.
But I do think to answer
your question there,
we are headed in the
right direction at least.
- Yeah, yeah.
I mean, that's a really
helpful story to hear,
I mean, just the way that came about too,
just the awareness,
the level of awareness.
'Cause like you said,
everybody was kind of going
through it in isolation
and the one person who had an experience
had no idea how common it was.
So yeah, that's really telling.
Esther, have you seen things
shift from your perspective?
- Yeah, I'm sort of going in circles
as I listen to Jeremy's story
because I do think we're
still so early in this process
as an Asian-American community,
as a global Asian community.
I mean, I think of how,
I mean, I almost remember to the day,
or at least the week or the era,
when I had conversations with my friends
about David Chang, the chef,
talking about his mental health
and how that was such a big
deal when he was so open
and wrote about it in his book.
And I remember mentioning it to a friend,
and Jeremy, your name came up
because it's like, it's
really cool to see,
even athletes, Asian athletes
talking about mental health like that.
And it's still in this era,
where when somebody who's
recognized and like comfortable
that you relate to,
like you guys talking about this topic,
it's still one of those,
like, people are surprised,
it's like this in a wonderful way,
but I still hear the
surprise in people's voices.
It's not like, oh yeah,
the 500th famous Asian person we know
is talking about mental
health, they all talk.
It's still this wow moment
because you don't,
I still react with surprise
and I mean, I'm much older than you are.
So I am carrying with me
kind of the expectations and norms
of a slightly different generation.
But I think for me and
my peers, there's this,
oh yeah, we can talk about this now.
It's like, we've all been
quietly going to therapy,
but now we can talk about this.
But I do see it more.
I do feel like the response is so positive
now that people are really
loving to see those messages.
I think from a researcher's perspective,
'cause so much of my time is in research.
When we talk about Asian
American and Pacific Islander
health disparities around mental health,
so much of it is just
the numbers part of it,
because of the reluctance to report
kind of collides with
our poor data collection
when it comes to any health problems
among Asian-Americans
and Pacific Islanders.
So I think, when you
think about all the steps
you need to take to appropriately
address a health problem,
you have to like understand the problem
and collect the data
and then devote the
appropriate resources to it
and develop good target outcomes
and you go through that
whole process a lot of times.
With Asian American
mental health problems,
we're really starting
at the data collection,
understanding the problem
because it's been so hard
to get people to report,
to seek help, to register as as a dot,
when you're looking at
all the health services
that are used, for example.
So I think some days
I feel like, wow, we've got so far to go
to actually feel like
we're robustly addressing
mental health problems.
And then there's times where I feel like
there's so many, increasingly
more inspirational stories
and people so hungry to hear those stories
and feel like, okay, like
that conversation can happen.
And people like Jeremy and David,
are making these huge,
it's like (imitating the
sound of an explosion)
just like a single voice like that.
I feel like has these huge ripple effects,
it gives people permission
to have those conversations
with their friends,
to use people that are well known
as kind of a starting point
for those conversations.
And that didn't happen when I grew up.
Never, never, I can't think
of a single Asian person
that I looked up to who
really used mental health
as like a major part of what
they wanted to talk about.
So just hearing it, seeing it now
is incredibly moving
and makes me feel like,
ah, there's hope.
- Yeah. Yeah.
I mean, it sounds like
a breath of fresh air
in a lot of ways too,
which is really, really important.
I mean, you also highlight
so many important topics
of where things need to move also,
in terms of some of the one
to two year old statistics
saying that 23% of those
from the AAPI community
actually seek out help.
So, Jeremy, even as you
were sharing your story,
part of what I was wondering
was like, okay, well, all
those people were hearing that
from each other for the first time,
one layer of me wonders like,
did people actually seek out help
when they were going
through those panic attacks
or were people walking
through that in isolation?
And so like I had a mixed feeling
like I was, oh, I'm so glad
this is actually happening
in terms of the conversations,
people are realizing,
but I'm also hoping that that level
of not having gotten to that point,
isn't happening on a larger
scale in some ways to,
not to be pessimistic,
but that's kind of where my mind went
hearing both of those.
And so I wonder if you
all would be willing
to talk about that aspect too.
Like, are there ways that we
as a society or individuals
can help people move to that place
of actually wanting to seek out their help
or just still the stigma
that really needs to kind
of be broken down first?
Like where do you see
some of the tension points
and areas where we can move that forward?
- Okay, I'll go, I guess.
- I'm leaving it to you,
open ended.
- I agree a lot with Dr. Choo,
that a lot of times when
you say these things,
there's a lot of shock.
But then by the end of the conversation,
it seems to always moving a good place.
So going back to that story,
I shared, I was going through therapy.
They were there with me
when, not in the room,
but they were waiting for me to get out,
when I went through that 11 week period
of being confined in a very small room.
And that's when I started therapy
and so as I was talking
about it with them,
there's mixed reactions
for some people when they were talking
about their panic attacks,
like some people they didn't even know,
they're like, "Oh, so it's
called a panic attack."
Like people were like, "Oh."
Another friend was like,
I actually went online
and I researched and I was like,
"What is this and why is this happening?"
And then that's how he came to
realize it was panic attacks.
Then other people have figured it out
and trying to do something about it.
And so this is an array
of kind of how everybody deals with it,
but the truth is the reality is still
that like nobody at that table
ever talked about with
anybody else at that table
and didn't know that
everyone was going through it
and so for me, it's like, again,
it's like you're scratching the surface
of what it could or should be.
But at least now we're
scratching the surface
and we're kind of starting
to bang at that door.
And even for me, when
I share to tell people
like, "Hey, I started therapy."
I almost have to like, my eyes are open,
but in my mind I almost close
my eyes for next three seconds
because every time I say that
a lot of people are like, are like,
"Wait, what happened?,"
or are like, "Why?"
And so I have to like blind
myself to like the shock.
Otherwise it'll make me
feel a little insecure,
like, "Ooh, shoot somethings wrong with me
or what am I doing or
am I sure I need it."
And so even when I say it,
I kind of just say like,
"Hey, let them have the
reaction they're gonna have,"
and then explain it
and talk about it a
little bit more in depth.
And typically by the end,
and it's kind of what you said
on the beginning of this podcast,
like authenticity always works the best.
And if I just share for my heart,
they kind of realize, "Oh, wow,
I probably struggle with
some level of anxiety.
I probably have some of
these foreboding thoughts.
I probably process emotions inadequately,
and experiences inadequately
that affect me in the long term."
And so I think there's
just a certain level
of, again, you're breaking
through that stigma
of like, "Oh, just because I go to therapy
means X, Y, or Z
and that's not where I'm
at, so I don't need that.
I'm not like one of them,"
is kind of the mentality
that some people might have.
So, yeah, I agree,
there's a long way to go,
but at least we're starting
and it does seem like for the most part,
I've had much more stories
of people being very
positive and receptive
about hearing about it than the other way.
- I think that's really great.
You're giving people that grace too.
I mean that that's a fine line to walk,
giving them the grace to kind of react,
but then also protecting
yourself in a sense too,
so you don't start to second guess
the choices and decisions
that you've made,
which are also very, very helpful.
So definitely commend that
'cause that's not easy.
- Can I ask, I'm sorry,
I'm so sorry if this is off topic,
I'm really curious about this 11 weeks.
Did you know going in it would
be about that time period?
Was it persistent
positive tests or symptoms
or how did it end up being,
that seems like a very long time.
- Yeah, well, I think, generally speaking,
the test standards here
is about, I would say, like
three to 4x more strict
in terms of like the bacteria count.
And so the typical, I remember, for me,
it was like they were expecting,
on average two to three
weeks and I'd be fine.
The problem is I have a broken nose
I broke my nose many
times from basketball.
and so I couldn't flush out the dead virus
from my nasal cavity fast enough.
And so I would have these like
really inconsistent tests.
And so I would have a
ton of dead bacteria,
but it was getting picked up
and it was enough to be positive.
So what it was actually pretty crazy
is there's a protocol for how you test out
and you had to get negative
on back to back tests.
And so I did that and I
had the hospital COVID test
and then I had the CDC
COVID test, now it's fine.
And I went back into to restart
my 21 day hotel quarantine.
And then on the seventh
day, I retested positive,
even though for me, I was vaccinated.
And so there was a lot of yeah.
or, sorry, not bacteria,
virus, but the dead virus.
And so that was the main issue.
And so I had to go back
again and then stay there
for a few more weeks until it
came back completely clean.
It was tough because like this whole time,
my whole like signature
shoe launch, my Asia tour,
the start of my season,
like everything that I had
prepared for, I lost all of it.
And so I missed a third of my season
and because I was vaccinated,
I actually was asymptomatic for,
out of those 77 days,
I was asymptomatic for the
last, like 60 something.
And I never had too many symptoms,
but that's just how it goes.
And so really to be honest, at that point,
it was more about like my body.
I think I lost like 15,
20 pounds of like weight
because I couldn't work out
and I couldn't get
enough food in my system.
And then also just my mind,
and that's where I'll be very transparent
is like being in this
tiny little hospital room
and there's no windows
that directly see outside.
And by the end it was like,
I didn't even want to be awake.
And so I started to have this
suicidal ideation of like man,
and my goal every day
was to try to wake up as late as possible
and to try to be as awake
for as little as possible.
There were days
where I wouldn't even
want to get out of bed.
I would just be laying there
and breakfast would be put there.
The nurse would walk in, put breakfast
and the nurse would walk in, put lunch,
and I wouldn't even touch the
food or turn on the lights,
and they're like, "Are you okay?
Are you still sleeping?"
And it's just like, I have no motivation.
I can't stare at these four walls anymore.
Like talking to myself all day.
And so that was when I
really hit a low point.
And I was like, yeah,
I'm gonna go to therapy.
And I started therapy
and in the past, I've worked
with sports psychologists
and other things like that
but this was like for me
as a person holistically.
and so that was my experience.
It was something that
- Oh my gosh
- I'll never forget for sure.
- Especially that piece where
you moved towards getting out
and then got yanked back in
just must have been so
crushing to have that hope
and then to be back to square one.
I think a lot of it is about expectations.
If you're told from the outset
that it's gonna be this amount of time,
but to have it kind of so
uncertain the entire time
must have just been crushing
for your brain and your spirit.
- Oh, it was so crushing
because the thing is like,
my first negative test came on day 10,
but I didn't officially clear out
of the entire thing until day 77.
So for the last 67 days,
I'm thinking I'm almost
there, I'm almost there.
And again, it's called (speaking
in a foreign language),
when you retest positive,
I was so upset that like
my luggage and things,
there were some very expensive
some stuff where I was like
I don't even want it anymore.
I was so angry and I was sweating
and like, no, this can't be happening.
It was like a nightmare.
And then like, you take the
test at 5:30 in the morning,
you need to wait until 9:00 PM
at night to get your results.
And so like the whole day is like,
I'm just like, and every
time a nurse walks by,
I'm like, "Oh, a nurse just walked by.
Are they coming in? Oh,
it's bad news again."
And it's just like thing
where on the outside looking in,
if I tell the story now I'm
like, oh, it sounds bad.
But to actually go through it
and to go through that
for 11 straight weeks
watching all my hard work and everything
that I prepared for dwindle
and watching my body just atrophy.
It was like, and like you
said, the expectation of it.
The up and down, that was a killer.
If I came in and someone's just
like, it's gonna be 77 days,
I'll be like, all right,
mentally lock in, I'm good.
I just gotta find a
way to make it through.
I got a little countdown,
but it's because I kept thinking
I'm right around the corner,
I'm right around the corner.
And then it'll be like, just kidding.
- That's wild.
- That's tough.
- It does make me think too about,
it's something you said really early on,
which is that mental
health is just health.
And I mean, when you described
I going through that,
I actually think it would be abnormal
if you didn't have an adverse
mental health consequence
from that,
just kind of like you're
in a big car accident
and it's normal for you to be injured.
It's like, I don't actually
know any person on earth,
no matter how mentally
strong they think are,
that could go through that
experience and not have,
just like we talked a lot
about that in healthcare,
how in the pandemic,
when we were all like in
the hospital all the time,
we were fearing for
ourselves and our families
and watching these people
drown in their own secretions.
And there was so much
uncertainty and we were scared
and people are like, yeah,
you know, if you need it,
we have these resources for mental health.
And at some point we are kind of like,
what if we just say,
we're gonna assume you
all need mental health
because in this circumstance,
having an adverse symptom
of mental health is normal,
like who would not have
anxiety, depression,
hopelessness, PTSD.
So let's just package in
some mental health there
and if you don't need
that, you can opt out.
I just feel like, could
we have a more proactive,
especially for people who
have a hard time asking for it
because of cultural reasons and norms,
it seems like maybe the
system can do a little more,
maybe healthcare can do a little more
to say a normal symptom
would be for you to need
some therapy, medication,
support groups around now, you know?
But I mean that your experience is,
I mean, that's gotta be a
very extreme human experience
to go through and I cannot imagine.
- Yeah. I mean, everything
you said is so, so important.
Yeah, 'cause Jeremy, as
you're describing that,
I mean all the (indistinct),
like what we do in studies,
basically you went through all that.
If you just add on
uncertainty over uncertainty,
over uncertainty, changing
expectations, lack of motivation,
like those are all the things
like from a brain standpoint
that lead people to just that
state of being overwhelmed,
not wanting to get up,
get outta bed, do things.
So, I mean, exactly as you were saying
like just needing to have those
things in place, proactively
I think is so important
because in a lot of ways,
when we're trying to look at those things
in laboratory settings,
we're trying to model
chronic unpredictable stress
is the term that people use.
And that's exactly like, as you described,
that's exactly what
you were going through.
And I think what made it so difficult?
But also, I'm encouraged
that you took the time
to say, okay, I am actually
going to look into therapy
and not just let this be the way it is
and to break through that, as well.
I mean, one question I also wanted ask you
and have Esther also chime in,
because I can only
imagine there's so much,
you must have learned going through that
because it was so difficult.
What are the things that
you've taken from that,
that you're trying to
hold onto moving forward?
Because I would imagine there are lessons
and things that you've
learned in that moment
that you don't just want to
keep there in that moment.
- Yeah, I think tying it back
into all of mental health,
I think one of the lessons that I learned
is when people decide
whether they need mental health support,
they're acting as their own doctor.
And so if you ask somebody
who smokes regularly,
they'll be like, "Oh, I'm okay.
Like I can still play
basketball, I can still work out.
I can still do,"
and it's like, "Yeah, but
if you go on long enough,
like there's gonna be adverse effects,"
but they're their own doctor.
And what I realized with my mental health
was even in the past,
when I had been more resistant to it,
it was like, I don't
and it's what Dr. Choo just said,
no one comes out the same.
That's a fact but it's
whether you realize it or not.
And so for me, I realized
a lot of these experiences
were having effects,
I just didn't realize it at the time.
And so compartmentalizing
it or sweeping under the rug
does not count as like I'm okay,
because that will build up
and that will come back to get you
somewhere later down the
road in a different way.
And you have to be aware of that.
And so that's my like spiel
on saying that when I went
through this situation,
when I got out, I was
like, I'm finally out.
and I had this like breath of fresh air,
even just to feel the sun,
even to be able to walk down the hall,
walk out that door and walk down the hall
or to go down an elevator.
Like these things.
My first time walking down the street,
I almost was freaking out
I saw all the lights, the cars,
because I was like there's so much noise.
And I was just so excited to live life
and I was like, okay, that part is over.
And then I got into the season
and in the season I
started off really poorly
because my body was
inactive for three months.
And I realized during the season,
I remember after one of my worst games,
I was like, I'm gonna quit,
I just want to go home.
Like, I don't wanna
play basketball anymore.
After a bad game, I wouldn't
normally respond that way.
And I started to think like,
why am I so lacking motivation?
Why do I want out so bad?
What is wrong with my mindset?
Like, I've never been like
this in my whole career.
And that's when I realized,
okay, what happened there
and the amount of energy and the damage
and the trauma that I
took, is affecting me now,
even though I didn't expect it to happen.
And so I think that's really important
to know that as you go
through these experiences,
they're building up and
they're changing you
and are changing the way you think,
and they're changing like for me,
they changed my persistence
factor and my perseverance,
because I just went
through something that.
And so again, if you ask
me, when I first got out,
I'd be like, dude, I'm ready,
I'm ready for the season.
I'm ready for basketball,
like, I'm tired of every,
I'm so excited.
Now, the minute that at basketball
started, I realize, dang,
I have almost have nothing,
I'm running on empty tank.
And so that's like one of
the biggest things I learned
is that like, if you're not processing
and healthily processing
everything you're going through,
it is continuing to
change your subconscious
and the way that you think
over and over and over again.
And that, like I said,
you don't wanna wait
until the person who's
smoking two packs a day
does not want to wait
until the worst diagnosis
to go and do something about it, right?
And so that would be maybe
an analogy I would use yeah,
for what I experienced
with my mental health.
- Yeah, that's great.
That's really, really
telling in a lot of ways too.
I'm not gonna jump been
to all neuroscience,
even though I have that tendency,
but just to mention like
everything you said,
like we often talk about,
the experiences they change our brains,
whether that's positive experiences
or challenging traumatic experiences,
like what you had gone
through and that has effects.
And so you were seeing some of that happen
even though you weren't
in that situation anymore.
So I think it's so important
that you were paying attention to that.
I think that can go a long way
to empower people, as well.
We haven't talked about necessarily
within AAPI communities,
but just trying to help
people think about,
when we're talking about mental health,
we are actually talking about our brains
and our brains do react
to different situations
and change in different situations,
which impacts how we
act in other situations.
So I mean, the way that
you brought that up,
I think is also important,
but just then again,
that level of awareness
that I think is huge.
So I know we're running, short on time.
This conversation definitely has flown by.
Esther, I was just gonna,
if there's a last word
that you also want to mention
then I'll pass it back
on to Jeremy to close.
It's up to you, but.
- Oh, I'm still kind of
sitting in what you said,
'cause I think there's
so much truth to that.
So I won't add onto it.
I just think every word you said
is what I wish I said
better and more often
to my patients and anyone who listens
when I message, and even my kids.
So thank you for all that.
- Yeah, really important
and really well said.
Well, there was so much
that you all brought in this conversation.
I felt like this have
gone on for much longer.
I know there's other topics we
could have pulled in as well,
but perhaps maybe at
some point in the future,
we'll have a, can't promise,
but another iteration
of this in some sense,
'cause I think there's
a of important topics,
but definitely appreciate you
all making the time to be here
on this podcast.
Everything that you've shared so honestly,
I mean just kind of walking through
what you've walked through,
but also the hope that we
have moving forward, as well.
And I know we didn't touch
on the faith component,
but I know that's also a
very, a very big part of this.
And again, for me just saying,
integrate into faith
with what we understand about
the brain and psychology
and our experiences,
I think it's so important for us all
to help ourselves get to a
better place as a community.
Not necessarily we're
trying to do ourselves,
but having the community
and having that divine
intervention, as well.
So definitely appreciate both of you.
I know this is gonna be an episode,
that lots of folks will get a lot from,
and hopefully will continue
to help break the stigma,
even as people hear your stories, as well.
So appreciate both you
and the time you've
taken to be here today.
- Thank you so much, Nii.
- Oh, thank you.
(gentle upbeat music)